we'll wait for this plane to go by
because we are professionals which means
time for chips hi guys I'm here at crab
stick hey that's me that's him
Chris Kendall we just accorded an
episode of not too deep which was
hilariously not that deep I didn't learn
anything about do not tip at all so make
sure you guys go over to SoundCloud
after this and check out the full
interview with Chris he answered a lot
of viewer questions and mostly mine but
now we're gonna play a game are you
excited
um yes yeah you're having emotions
whether their excitement we'll find out
I thought it'd be really fun because you
just got off a plane and you are here in
America for the first time do you play
the say anything challenge I'm not sure
what it is okay here's how it works we
go back and forth saying anything no no
yeah you can only say one word back and
forth that time literally anything you
can't repeat a word yeah and also I
played this with Hannah before you can't
just say sentences I always say it's one
way it's one word so it literally be
like chair cushion my own bow ah but you
can't be like I cushion think chair cuz
that's a different game
yeah that's not fair that's what that
game is called and then what happens is
if you stutter or you can't think of a
word or you say or if you repeat a word
the other person gets to put a piece of
tape on your face okay yeah it's that
makes total sense it seems like it's not
a huge consequence but it is shocking
how terrible the face can get when you
insert tape so you understand yeah are
you excited yeah
all right let's play Wow doing
straightaway yeah
would you like to go first
doing warm-ups my vocals it just sounds
a little bit like an asthma attack but
if that's your process yeah that's my
process okay I'll start
red yellow chair pink curtain house
screen happy camera man oh I'm always so
bad at this game I start freaking out
it's so simple okay here you get to put
tape on my face you can use a huge piece
of toast
yeah don't feel limited I mean in
America we're very wasteful so welcome
to America yeah all right huh I'm gonna
give you like it
Colonel Sanders type oh you're very nice
about this game why well I'm not gonna
be this nice to you just so you know
okay take it easy yes she's starting
real easy here we go I'll let you begin
mm-hmm tight finger yeah I don't want to
up your beautiful beautiful hair well
let's see uh I can make it happier oh I
see it you that look like a Star Wars
guy yeah the jedis the Jedi's have made
it through the door that's nice okay
ready
um wait wait I got with the mouth taped
open it makes it very easy for your
vocal exercises I'll let you start
mmm crisps cup house celery
Boh rug carpet sir yeah Oh God all right
why does it get like intense why does it
get like that's the thing that makes you
hard but it's calming your own brain oh
my god mmm-hmm yeah there we go that
feels right what secure yeah feels great
so don't let me
that's um my work done Oh what are you
talking about I've just been like
juicing okay ready
I'll let you start dog fire man roof
House fence garden no yeah yeah yeah
sure how didn't is a tricky what to say
I was generated I'm gonna move your
beautiful hair you look good okay let's
see I don't want to cut your hair no you
look beautiful
you look very la right now la okay you
need to blink I can fix it so you can
boy I get some drops yeah yeah let me
Fake this at your eyelashes wait I don't
know I take it to your eyelashes I don't
want to eyeball oh okay nice Oh Mike
there you go all right
you look still very beautiful okay ready
okay here we go
wire man cord happy internet man let's
make you look like a man okay
I got a sticky if he knows it's gonna
yeah you look real is my new look I'm
I'm happy to accommodate
Chris's la makeover last round
are you ready okay yeah okay I'll let
you start
okay moon wood forest tree axe
easy acts you could have had any item
yeah I could uh see this is string of
this is being a gracious host um let's
do there's a lot of okay great okay
feels great yeah definitely not panic
attack inducing at all oh no
okay let's play one bonus round bone
around but that's not a real word I'll
let you scar what why we start okay what
were you start yeah yeah yeah okay water
cup that's alright hold on anyway you
know root you have I thought you'd
failed no I said that's a word I know
it's a word but that's usually you
usually swear when you fail yeah but
this time it was always it we need safe
words okay there we go
let's see okay oh yes
are you much better than this it's like
don't forget to subscribe because this
is groundbreaking and if you want to see
what you can expect from Oscar's hotel
just look at this freaking you click a
link below grizzle thank you for being a
willing participant make sure you guys
go check out crash sticks
watch the pilot of the sunroom Oscar's
hotel and go over to SoundCloud or
iTunes and listen to the full podcast
not too deep with grace Belges and Chris
Kendall aka cross sticks I don't know
how many times have you been in LA
before if this is base my first time in
America this year wait this is your
first time in America I'm not good
traveling so and you came here
the Iowa I apologize I apologize I'm
like what do we how do we show you a
better time than
Oh